12 horas de alto el fuego para evacuar
algunas zonas bombardeadas el resultado
de las últimas conversaciones
ruso-ucranianas confirmadas de esta
mañana en kiev fue otro modo de poquito
numerito nosotros hemos recibido una
notificación de la federación rusa sobre
la aprobación de nuestras rutas
previamente propuestas
los militares acuerdan un alto al fuego
de 9 de la mañana a 9 de la noche tiene
fotos
se utilizarán un total de 6 corredores
humanitarios para la evacuación de
civiles supone que uno de ellos permite
a los habitantes de las ciudades del
oeste de kiev entrar en la capital pero
sin forma de que el fuego de artillería
se mantiene los otros cinco corredores
están en el este del país incluso desde
mariupol una ciudad portuaria en el
sureste que ha sido asediada y saqueada
desde la semana pasada donde los
anteriores intentos de alto el fuego y
evacuación de civiles han fracasado
ambas partes se culpan mutuamente
300.000 personas están a la espera de
salir en su me una ciudad del norte
cercana a la frontera rusa también
afectada por el alto el fuego unas 5000
personas fueron transportadas al centro
del país en unos 60 autobuses por su
parte moscú afirma que se han hecho
progresos en las negociaciones
humanitarias pero sigue defendiendo la
idea de evacuar a la población del este
de ucrania a su territorio
pues vuelve a poco access cerca de dos
millones de personas han pedido ser
evacuadas de rusia y 140.000 ya han
cruzado a territorio ruso
y si había cifras imposibles de
verificar como la autenticidad de las
imágenes difundidas por el ministerio de
defensa ruso éstas muestran la
distribución de ayuda humanitaria en la
región de hardcore